♪ ♪ ♪ve de Marianne semble
tout simple : trouver une
adolescente qui s'occupera de
sa mignonne petite fille
MARIANNE CADIEUX
- Moi ce que je voyais,
c'était un bloc de quatre heures
le samedi, exemple un 8 à midi
pour comance avec mon bébé,
puis créer une relation parce
que ce que je voulais, c'est
une gardienne qui suive dans
mon enfant.
imerait avoir un peu de
temps pour faire des tâches dans
la maison ou pour
- Je me disais : si je suis
présente sur place, je devraisis
avoir encore plus un bassin
plus large, parce que la
Pis j'étais pas capable
de trouver non plus.
- Pourtant, elle est prête à
payer jusqu'à 15 - C'est entre $
de l'heure, sans reçu.
- Moi, je trouvais que 15 $ de
l'heure, c'était tout à fait $ e
l'heure, je trouve ça vraiment
abusé. Surtout dans la mesure
où c'est en dessous de la table.
dans une demi-douzaine de
Facebook avec une seule
condition : aucun cellulaire
pendan
- On me disait que le jeune
était réfractaire à venir
s'il ne pouvait pas employersonr
le lieu de garde et que c'était
à moi de changer ma perception
d'un bébé qui se tient pas
encore tout seul, assis.
- Il y a le manuel "Gardiens
avertis"!
- Avec la pandémie, le nombre
de jeunes qui suivent le cours
Gardiens avertis est passé,
au Québec, de 40 000 à 30 000
par année.
ELÉONOR MAGEOT, animatrice Atout
Plus, Croix-Rouge canadienne
- Il y en a facilen a facilen a%
des participants qui sont déjà
attendus, parce qu'il y a des
amis de la famille, des voisins
qui attendent qu'ils aient leur
certificat de part
Ça peut être comme des
couleurs...
- Et les parents doivent bien
les payer pour profiter de
leurs services.
- Ils sont habitués à cinq!
Sauf que cinq, c'est...
il y a 25, 30 ans, c'était cinq!
- La formatrice suggère
aux jeunes de demander
7 et 15 $ de l'heure.
- Ça s'approche du salaire
parce que la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre fait que qu'on
va chercher les jeunes beaucoup
plus tôt pour aller travailler
au dépanneur ou dans
un restaurant rapi
Vous voyez le trait au milieu?
- Les familles devraient,
selon elle, donner au moins
10 $ de l'heure.
- C'est une reconnaissance
et une stimulation pour
les avoir comme plus sérieux
gardiennage, plus
longtemps.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Annie, elle, l'a trouvéesa peà
Elizabeth, la maman peut
sortir quelques heures
et souffler un peu.
- Juste aller faire l'épicerie.
Dollarama Dollarama Dollarama ,
amener la tribu au Dollarama,
c'est comme faire les Jeux
olympiques. Aller au cinéma,
manger au restaurant. Tu sais,ce
tout le monde devrait avoir.
- La jeune fille a commencé
à garder des enfants il y a
environ quatre ans quand elle
avait 12 ans.
- C'est passionnant. Ça dégage
de l'énergie, c'est le fun.
C'est vraiment flexible. Tu peux
t'arranger avec les parents. Ils
comprennent aussi les besoins
puis c'est occasionnel, t'sais.
Tu peux rencontrer plein
de gens.
- Elle demande normalement
10 ou 12 $ de l'heure.
- Il y en a beaucoup qui offrent
plus, 15 $ de l'heure. Ça dépend
aussi de leurs besoins. Souvent,
c'est vraiment juste pour
la garde des enfants. C'est
rare qu'ils demandent de faire
du ménage, de la vaisselle
ou d'autres choses. Ils payent
le repas, donnent des affaires.
Ils veulent vraiment nous
garder, là t'sais.
- Et ses services sont trè
en demande.
- J'ai pas fait d'annonce.
J'en fais pas, ça sert à rien,
parce que je vais avoir trop de
messages. C'est vr
bouche à oreille, parce que
ça "pop" de même, des fois.
- D'ailleurs, Annie se trouve
très chanceuse qu'Élizabeth
soit la
c'est ce qui lui a permis de
la rencontrer.
- Elle est tellement
exceptionnelle que je lui
e la marraine
du bébé.
- Wow!
- Oui, j'ai vraiment là...
Élizaous
le dis, c'est comme gagner
1 million de dollars de l'avoir.
- Marianne, de son côté,
continue.
- Moi, ce que j'aimerais
trouver, c'est une petite
gardienne qui veut créer
ma fille
sur une longue période, là.
Une petite Mary Poppins
des temps modernes.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal